in seven and a half billion years the
Sun will expand and engulf our planet
destroying all life as we know it of
course a mass extinction on earth could
happen much sooner than that it might
even be our fault
sooner or later humans might have to
leave Earth to find a new home but while
that might sound scary
not to mention impossible some say it's
already been done millions of years ago
by organisms much smaller than us and
not nearly as smart this is what if and
here's what would happen if ancient life
escaped from Earth
imagine that millions of years ago a
comet sailed through the outer
atmosphere of Earth the comet flew high
enough to avoid burning up in the
atmosphere but just low enough to pick
up some extremely determined microbes
the stowaway microbes embedded
themselves deep within the pores of the
speeding comet sheltering themselves
from the radiation of deep space eons
later the comet crashed into a planet in
another solar system and the surviving
microbes began to grow in their new home
according to two astrophysicists at
Harvard University this might actually
have happened but if earthly microbes
did succeed in trading our planet for a
new one does that mean that we could one
day do the same microbes are small in
size but huge in numbers the most recent
estimates say that there are roughly one
trillion different microbe species
living on earth and while we have yet to
discover 99.999% of them the microbes we
do know are vital to our survival at
least fifty percent of the oxygen on
earth is produced by photosynthetic
microorganisms like algae and
cyanobacteria
and before the evolution of plants
microbes were the own
oxygen producers on earth so with that
in mind and assuming humans would
continue to rely on oxygen to survive we
might actually need microbes in space to
support our lives on other planets if
the earthly microbes hitchhiking on a
comet millions of years ago theory is
correct
then there could be another planet out
there with a habitat that's similar to
ours on earth
unfortunately this alternate earth would
be in another solar system and humans
have only traveled as far as the moon
the best way to test this theory would
be to send microbes to Mars or other
nearby new earth candidates with the
hope that they'd be able to foster an
atmosphere we could live in if the
microbes we sent from Earth succeeded in
creating an atmosphere like ours and
laying the foundations of a food chain
we'd have a much better chance of
building a new future for ourselves
unfortunately it's hard to predict how
microorganisms will respond to being in
space in some cases bacteria can become
less harmful but in other cases they can
grow faster and become much more
dangerous we don't know how our microbes
could affect any existing ecosystems on
other planets
they could become an invasive species
that would drive the native life on
other planets to the brink of extinction
and it's hard to say how the microbes we
sent would evolve on a new planet sure
we might get some new plants on a new
planet but what kinds of plants there's
also the fear that if microbes can
successfully planet hop through space
then earth is equally at risk of being
hurt by them if alien microbes infected
earth it could lead to the development
of new diseases that we couldn't cure
and without a cure to some unknown
untreatable alien epidemic that might
suddenly appear on our planet we might
be forced to leave our home world after
all but before you start aggressively
searching for a place to by NASA
approved spacesuits you should know that
we're far from having a
we developed theory on space traveling
microbes after all we're still learning
things about the biology of our
atmosphere which makes understanding how
it might have been hundreds of millions
of years ago even more challenging we
also don't know just how long even the
most dedicated microbes could survive we
know that tardigrades for example can
live for decades and they're able to
survive the harsh environment of space
but can tardigrades or anything else
live long enough to make it to an
entirely different solar system that
remains to be seen
or maybe not we don't know exactly when
humans might actually have to leave
Earth but what if we knew the exact time
Earth was going to die well that's a
story for another what-if